welcome to the first of five video
guides of our new turn-based strategy
RPG blackguards featuring the dark I
universe and developed by date Dalek
entertainment today everything revolves
around the first decision you have to
make in the game what character class
will you pick you have three initial
choices fighter mage or hunter as well
as male or female you can also fully
customize your character without
sticking to an archetype but more on
that later on the fighter is a melee
specialist wearing heavy armor and
soaking a lot of damage before going
down wielding swords axes and other
instruments of violence the fight is
excellently suited for dealing damage he
is a frontline grunt keeping enemies at
bay and using various special abilities
to exploit each opponent's weak spots
however since he is most effective in
melee range he is vulnerable to ranged
attacks no matter of arrows Oh magic
enemies with these capacities can hurt
him at range before the fighter can
close the gap and return the favor
the mage is the only class who can wield
magic Acosta's arcane powers may
manifest in various ways there are not
only devastating combat spots affecting
singer opponents or taking effect in
whole areas the Wizards tricks of the
trade are vast letting your own shadow
join the fray summon a magical barrier
make enemies go berserk among their own
allies as long as they don't run out of
astral power mages can always turn the
tide of battle the mage should keep his
distance however metal armor impairs
magic and wearing only light armor makes
a poor choice for frontline melee combat
the hunter is mainly a skilled ranged
fighter but in contrast to the mage the
hunter relies on bow and arrow instead
of magic with an arsenal of different
poles and arrows and I can take out
dangerous foes at long range at the same
time those versatile fighters can hold
their own in melee combat as well
hunters thus find a place in a hybrid
row between fighter and mate as they
have always the right tool for the job
no matter which fur they face on the
battlefield these three classes aren't
enough for you the dark eye sourcebooks
of a much larger variety of professions
you say we are aware of that and that's
why you can completely individualize
your a guitar build while playing black
arts even though a fighter may be most
comfortable with heavy plates sword mace
or X there's no need to stick to melee
only the fighter can fire a crossbow or
set traps to expose enemies just as well
mages don't need to hide in the back if
you want your mage to become the terror
of the frontlines put on a leather armor
and learn area of effect spells
that'll teach any foe what it means to
get in close quarters with a
well-prepared caster last but not least
our hunter has one or the other trick up
her sleeve when equipped with a spear or
similar polum she can keep an opponent
at distance you can't touch her but she
can still stab you with the pointy end
specializing like this is possible
thanks to the detailed blackout skill
system how this works and how you can
fully customize your character right
from the beginning will be the topic of
our second black arts video guide there
we will show you various hints in
regards of customizing your character
right away and now it's your turn
show us your character and tell your own
story right here on YouTube or hit the
forums and exchange experiences about
your journeys through aventura on forum
dot date Dalek dot de you can also of
course find us on Facebook here you can
stay up to date about recent information
on date Daleks black guards background
information and anything important is I
was supposed it here
ww black arts de who didn't join the
black arts yet but wants to catch up as
fast as possible is more than welcome to
register on steams early access there's
also an awesome collector's edition
featuring an art book a figurine and
much more cool content